on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
good evening and welcome
Edition at Piers Morgan uncensored live
from Doha in Qatar the home of course of
the World Cup and tonight I'll be
talking exclusively to the World Cup
Chief Hassan al-tawadi who answers the
critics
is it safe for gay people to be in Qatar
now yes
yes
and they were the two most famous people
in British football Richard keys and
Andy Gray were the dominant front men
for Sky's coverage of the Premier League
but then it all came crashing down in a
sexism Scandal they now live here and
work here in Doha and tonight they give
me their first ever exclusive interview
since it all went down
I suddenly found myself at a really dark
place
um the house surrounded by people
uh and I knew I had
done something wrong of course I did
but I couldn't compute it
and my head was gone
[Music]
live from Qatar this is Piers Morgan
uncensored at the World Cup
foreign
for the World Cup uh in Qatar welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored a competition
that began in a blaze of hypocritical
sanctimony has become what it always
should have been a feast of great
football with unpredictable results
Unforgettable drama and a billion
eyeballs glued to the biggest sporting
event on the planet that's how it should
be for the past few weeks it's been a
uniquely negative narrative about this
world cup driven I have to say mostly
from England here in Doha reality feels
very different I've been here for a few
days now and found a thriving
Cosmopolitan Sportsman City and a
stunning vantage point for a tournament
played out in magnificent purpose-built
stadiums that are filling up more with
every game I gotta say the conversation
in Qatar is less about rainbow
bucketheads hats and arm pads and more
about the football why is Gareth
Southgate leaving Phil foden on the
bench could anyone stop killing mbappe
how badly injured his Neymar could
Ronaldo or Messi's last World Cups end
in the biggest trophy of all and of
course is it coming home spoiler alert
probably not from here in Qatar the
tournament Bears no resemblance to all
the doom-mongering headlines back home
fans from across the world are safe and
mingling happily the stadiums are not
selling beer they're those who want to
drink alcohol can do soap all over the
city there's no sign of the shameful
booze fueled scenes of our own Euros
final at Wembley now of course Qatar is
not without fault women's rights and gay
rights are restricted by Western
standards migrant workers have
indispitably been treated badly
but those statements apply to many of
the countries around the world including
many competing in this tournament and by
many nations who've hosted major
sporting events without anything like
the furore that's kicked off about Qatar
we seem to have forgotten in England
that in 1966 when we hosted and won the
World Cup it was illegal to be gay in
our country
moral Halos appear to have slipped over
some people's eyes and escured some
rather Salient facts for example there's
12 of the population here are native
qataris something we and these
supposedly sophisticated West would
never tolerate the migrants who come
here in vast numbers are sometimes
mistreated but the reason they're here
in the first place is because the wages
they earn are life-changing and the
global scrutiny of the World Cup has at
least led to reforms in labor laws here
that will be an important Legacy and one
massively lacking after two Olympic
Games in China and a World Cup in Russia
Qatar is also a significant investor in
many aspects of UK life for example it
gives us 25 percent of our gas
which is Food For Thought isn't it is
our national grid considers winter
blackouts with all the virtue signalers
back home prefer we tell Qatar to stop
sending its gas
this tournaments brought the football
mad Middle East together as well two
years ago Qatar was under a blockade led
by Saudi Arabia Bahrain and the UAE now
fans from those countries are pouring in
to enjoy the football saudi's Crown
Prince was at the opening ceremony the
Emir of Qatar even waved a Saudi flag
during their stunning win over Messi's
Argentina
there's no denying the Middle East has a
long way to go on human rights and many
social issues but so frankly to a lot of
European countries there's also no
denying that this region the Middle East
has long deserved its World Cup
and there's no denying and I can tell
you this is what most people here are
thinking that right now qatar's putting
on a pretty good show
and frankly when it comes to morality
are we in England really in any position
to lecture the Middle East about laws or
values given the way we illegally
invaded Iraq 20 years ago sparked in two
decades of Isis Terror and at last
year's Euros final showed the world that
we're a bunch of coke snorting boost
sodden brawling firework exploding from
backside imbeciles
me thinks not
well Hassan al-tawadi is the Secretary
General of the Supreme committee for
delivery Legacy which is a fancy title
for he pretty well runs a World Cup here
in Qatar he's the man of the Helm of the
most controversial tournament in World
Cup history for reasons that frankly
baffled me and he spoke to me a little
earlier today I began by asking how he
felt about Qatar hosting the tournament
and how he thought he was going
we're immensely proud of of the World
Cup as you know and everything that's
been unfolded since uh since the 20th of
November it's it's a moment of great
pride I mean you know just just if you
look at what's happening on the streets
people from all over the world coming in
celebrating uh the story is unfolding in
the pitch the stadiums from a
footballing perspective phenomenal great
um well Saudi Arabia beating Argentina
for the region absolutely well
absolutely I mean you know and then and
then Morocco just recently beating
Belgium uh yesterday I mean that in
itself is a phenomenal story as well
this is the first World Cup in the Arab
world this is the first World Cup in the
Middle East in the Islamic world you see
it not only in you know not only in
terms of the teams participating but you
see it in the stadiums I mean I I was
seeing some of the punditry where you
had the fans it was predominantly red
Moroccan supporters and it's not just
Maracas flying over here it's supporters
of the Moroccan national team from the
Arab uh population Living in Qatar
visiting qatars Saudi supporters were
supporting Morocco Moroccan supporters
who are supporting Saudi and Tunisia and
so on uh you know for our part of the
world for our region this is this is a
you know I have to say you know as
qataris as Arabs we're extremely proud
of this moment how have you reacted as a
senior Qatari one of the real key people
in this world cup
particularly from the criticism from the
UK for example
I think you know from day one what we
tried to do is distinguish between two
forms of criticism
there's constructive criticism
that we've taken on board we've engaged
with uh we've talked to our critics who
had a genuine interest in terms of you
know progress or working with us towards
utilizing this this tournament as a
transformational vehicle for Qatar and
for the region and as I said we've
engaged with them we've discussed things
with them and they've become Partners in
the end and then there's of course
criticism that I think is based on uh
misinformation
uh misrepresented facts misstated facts
and even even towards you know these and
whether it's whether it's media Outlets
or individuals we've also reached out
and tried to engage and tried to set the
facts straight
um and some unfortunately have not been
as as as
receptive of our efforts but
nevertheless we've always said one thing
the most important element is
um our response is always going to be by
actions as opposed to work
fronts the BBC coverage he's a friend of
mine full disclosure big fan of his work
over the years both on the pitch or not
but he did a sort of monologue at the
start of the BBC's coverage pointing out
all the bad things about Qatar I know
what I felt was he didn't do that at the
Russia World Cup
um they didn't run your opening ceremony
this time the BBC on the main Channel
they did in Russia they ran it for
example with the China Olympics in
Beijing Winter Olympics yes it seems to
me to be a bit of a double standard
though well it's it's it's it's
disappointing you know for an
institution such as a BBC especially you
know a particular BBC Sports in an
institution that has always known or at
least you know as I grew up was always
known to be you know objective and
stating the facts and allowing for you
know different points of view to be
addressed and for the audience to make
their own decision uh for the actions
that you've mentioned for example you
know and again in particular with Gary
the frustration is that we've reached
out to we've reached out to him many
times the latest if I'm not mistaken was
in February about three or four times
for a sit-down and at the very least
again with the idea we'll present our
case whatever judgment you want to pass
later on that's that's that's up to you
but at least for us to present the
counter argument show you know show what
what we've done how we've utilized this
tournament and how really this
tournament is a historical event what
you've seen stadiums and what you see
outside the engagement the cultural
engagement the funds the way people are
dressing yeah I mean I mean you know
just a little side Side Story you know
over the years as I did a lot of
interviews especially from back home I'm
always dressed like this and a lot of my
friends whether they're journalists and
even some experts always try to try to
convince me to dress in a western way
even from the Qatar dressed in a western
way why should we fall on you anything
frankly whether it's our our values that
we have in the UK the way we dress the
way we talk the way we drink I'm not
sure that we're in any position to take
the high moral ground as a country which
for example invaded Iraq illegally in
2003 an invasion I opposed as a
newspaper Predator does that give us
bragging rights on morality with the
Middle East I'm not sure that it does I
do want to turn to some things where I
think I I would say other criticism
notably migrant workers The Guardian
newspaper said that six and a half
thousand migrant workers have died as a
result of the World Cup Construction
I've looked into this I saw many other
fact checkers
figures deeply misleading us because
it's actually the number of migrants
who've died in total in the last 12
years since the bid was confirmed for
Qatar of any cause do you know how many
migrant workers have died as a result of
any construction since the announcement
of the bid in terms of you know what we
did from day one at least within the
organization that I'm responsible for as
we were committed towards being
transparent
and you know capturing any incidents
whether it's in terms of you know misses
near misses accidents or unfortunately
deaths and we decided to capture and we
made a decision in terms of obviously
work-related deaths as defined under the
you know industry standard but also
capturing what we consider to be
non-work related deaths and this only
purely in relation to the stadiums right
and the projects that we're responsible
for and what are those types and that's
three work-related deaths and 37
non-work related deaths right these are
the specific to World Cup construction
do you know how many people have died in
Qatar since you won the bid in the last
12 years from any construction related
to anything to do the World Cup in other
words new hotels new Bridges whatever
whatever in other words what is the
honest realistic total do you think of
Migrant workers who've died from as a
result of what they're doing for the
World Cup in totality
the estimate is around 400. before
between 400 and 500 I'm not I don't have
the exact number that's that's something
that's being discussed I mean there will
be people and Sony say that's a lot of
people
let me say 400 is a price too big to pay
what do you say to that
what I will say is
one death is a death too many plain and
simple
um and I think every year uh the health
and safety standards on the sites are
improving at least on our sites the
World Cup sites a lot like we're
responsible for most definitely to the
extent that you've got trade unions
representatives of the German Trade
union representatives of the Swiss
Traders would you accept I just just at
this point have commended the work
that's been done on on the site on the
World Cup side right and the Improvement
right but do you accept them because of
the improvements that have been made
that at the start they weren't good
enough the standards I think overall the
need for labor reform in itself dictates
that yes improvements had to happen and
just so we're clear this was something
that was recognized before we bid the
improvements that have happened isn't
because of the World Cup these are
improvements that we knew we had to do
because of our own values improvements
that have to happen whether it's in
terms of health and safety standards
whether it's in terms of improving
accommodations as standards whether it's
in terms of dismantling the Catholic
system now what the World Cup did the
World Cup served as a vehicle as an
accelerant as a catalyst and you know
because of the spotlight which we
recognized early on was going to be shed
it allowed you know it caused a lot of
these initiatives not only in terms of
improvement in the legislation but in
the enforcement of it as well and that's
where today you know where we let you
you know
we got to a position where
our most Ardent of critics consider us
today to be a benchmark in the region
let me ask you about LGBT rights because
a lot of furore about this and in
particular the wearing of the armbands
so the England Captain Harry Kane and
several of the European country captains
were all going to wear for one love
armband did you personally have any
problem with them doing that if it was
done specifically to address Qatar I had
a problem with it right if it was done
some you know for something that was
going to be done and the European
nations were going to be you know
holding you're just wearing it
continuously constantly then of course
that's a decision that they you know
that that's up to them it was FIFA right
to say if they wear it they'd all get
bookings
again it's a decision that FIFA's made
between them and and the European
nations and I think you know became a
standoff and that was a discussion that
was that was between them for me what
I'm trying to you know what what for our
position and my personal position is
look you know uh we've always said
everybody's welcome and and you know
we've worked very hard to create an
environment
um and to ensure that people from all
parts of the world and all walks of life
come into come coming to Qatar engage
and interact with people from the Arab
world and the Middle East
um even though they might not
necessarily see eye to eye on certain
things even though we might not agree on
certain things
um but everybody's welcome and the point
is you know to to to come to terms with
the fact that we won't see eye to eye
but we can still have mutual respect for
each other and still find a way of
moving forward celebrating together and
I think is it safe for gay people to be
in Qatar yes
unequivocally appears yes and safely gay
people to live in Qatar
yes
I think it's safe for everybody to live
in Catherine Pierce but there would be a
problem with a gay couple for example
showed demonstrative displays of public
displays of affection generally is not
part of our culture
public display of affection is not part
of our culture
um it's not you know regardless of
who you are regardless of your your
sexual identification or or and so on uh
public display of affection is not and
again I say that and I mean within
reason
um you know holding hands in the streets
is fine uh the gay people
holding hands in the streets for
anybody's fine it is
um
but what I'm saying is you know there's
there's you know public intimacy you
know public intimacy is not part of our
culture we're a relatively conservative
culture in the West
the the individual's personal rights
always Trump
um let's say the community rights that's
that's what's most sacred now there are
other societies our society being one of
them you know the Arab world in the
Middle East where it's the communal
values it's the values of the community
in society which is also again
fundamentally related to religion as
well that is that is a that is a you
know of a higher value of higher
importance and again the question then
becomes what is more important you know
if you're coming from a western
value-based system you look at
individual rights regardless of any
other uh aspect that should always be
sacred and from our part of the world
it's the religious values that are there
what I'm trying to say is at points in
time these discussions you know to try
to find a winner out of them or try to
find you know for somebody to kind of
defeat somebody else in terms of the
discussions
um the reality is that there will be no
winner but what we have to do is find
you know or at least that's what we try
to do is find common ground find
something at least that unites us and
come to terms with the fact that we
might not see eye to eye on certain
things but we have to find a way of
coexisting and moving forward and what
this world cup has showcased again
taking it back to what you see on the
streets taking back to it to where you
see the engagement taking it back to
where you're seeing you know the
Brazilian and the uh Saudi singing
where's Messi after the loss of after
the defeat of Argentina seeing the
argentinians coming in you know finding
the Saudis and saying where's that
solemn when they lost against Poland
looking at people dressing like you know
I've seen somebody dressing you know
wearing the film but in the Portuguese
flag I've seen the Croatian flag
um I saw a tweet yesterday that that for
me was just absolutely funny a guy
saying you know never in my life that
was I expecting to see a Spaniard
rushing because he's late to watch uh
the Spanish match holding on to his
headgear
um
what's happening outside
the celebration of cultures I want to
end on a positive it's been a positive
interview
um who's going to win the World Cup
you know give me a name I need a name
I'll save this back in three weeks I'll
say France France I think France led by
place
and the French team yes I think
actually I think England have a good
chance England have got a great job
Harry Kane remains fit and they play
phone
but I also think Portugal at a chance
with my friend Cristiano of course
because I think he's got a vision of
himself lifting that cup and they have a
very good side well you know just to be
fair as well for me I want England to
win so we're clear I don't want anyone
it'd be great to have you know uh
English football history connected to
Qatar forever yeah that's not thank you
very much thank you very much good to
talk to you thank you
well next tonight controversial football
pundits Richard keys and Andy Gray join
me to discuss their new life here in
Qatar and they speak for the first time
on UK TV about the extraordinary Fallout
from their sexist comments and got them
well the EPO from the sky
[Music]
I suddenly found myself at a really dark
place
um the house surrounded by people
and I knew I had
done something wrong of course I did
but I couldn't compute it
and my head was gone
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back to my live special
edition of Piers Morgan on census from
here in Doha Qatar the World Cup Richard
keys and Andy Gray were the famous faces
of Sky Sports Premier League coverage
for a generation I think this football
became a global sensation they became
household names but they lost it all in
a notorious Scandal over sexist comments
made off air about a female assistant
referee and they've since moved their
careers and their lives to here in Qatar
I spoke exclusively to them earlier in
their first UK TV interview in a decade
since it all went down
why did you say yes to me
well it's quite simple
you appears Morgan you're the governor I
cannot let your style yes you know I
think it would it be my mate here's a
style very much yeah I think
so we had a chat and it wasn't as you
you might suspect it wasn't a done deal
when we were asked but I gotta say to it
so that I'd like you talk to people we
are as my great friend late great Ray
Wilkins would say we are a tad or we're
a tad bruised yeah and so therefore we
withdrew entirely
um from from engaging with the British
media
um and and we've largely concentrated on
the opportunity that was afforded to us
here we've had an absolute ball for a
decade
um the other thing that I thought you
you were very fair about peers was your
attitude towards this world cup the
country friends that we've made in the
time that we've been here just to start
with the fact the World Cup's here you
guys have lived here for the last decade
what do you make of the way that
particularly in the UK there's been this
narrative about Qatar they shouldn't
have the World Cup it was one with
corruption there are all these problems
with LGBT rights
to me these are all legitimate concerns
agreed but I also think there's been a
lot of hypocrisy I don't remember this
outcry it's as intense as it's been in
for such a long time around Russia four
years ago I thought and that was four
years after they've invaded Crimea right
and with exactly the same record about
human rights when it comes to you LGBT
and so on and so on so I do feel there's
a lot of hypocrisy there's a war raging
in Yemen right
um but but my my view on uh yes there is
a lot of hypocrisy
um I none of us condone what what Putin
did has done and and would wish to do as
far as his Excursion into the Ukraine is
concerned but but I think that resonated
more in Europe because
white faces were being seen in in
distressing situations if the color of
the face is different it doesn't quite
resonate to the same degree
unfortunate as that is it's true so here
here we've had different Wars at
different times that we we've had to
come to terms with and they haven't
necessarily
made a a line of Copy in the UK so
yeah all of the things that have been
mentioned
we understand and I think the country
here more than any in this part of the
world understands but I think it was you
that made the point when I was listening
the other week if you accept the
principle that a World Cup is coming to
the Middle East and it should where are
you going to play it if not Qatar right
and by the way for the same reason she
then go and play it in Africa which has
many of the same issues to go to India
and you go to China I mean what about
four years from now in America
I love America yeah I've lived there on
and off for nearly 20 years but you know
I don't agree with some of their laws
we've done laws some of their estate
laws about abortions
um I wonder if people will take the high
moral ground about America's laws I
doubt they're willing with the same
ferocity I don't think it'll get a
mentioned peers because again it I I
refer you back to what I just said about
listen a lot of what the criticism
leveled at this country has has boarded
if not has been racist yes it has been
shocking please let me tell you about
you say overnight and and in all honesty
this country 11 now there's no
resemblance to the one I moved into 10
years ago
in what way and the way it has changed
it's its views its laws
um the kefala that used to be in here
that restricted people I think from
traveling and whatever that's that's all
been gone they're modifying everything
in that respect and they are trying to
move on but as you said they're doing it
slowly and maybe that's not to
everyone's satisfaction maybe it's too
slow if you were being critical what
would you say what would be your biggest
criticism
I think all of the issues that you can
maybe another couple of golf courses
yeah
yeah as factors should be taken as
seriously as they have been but you
can't use them to consistently whilst
change is taking place that's a at the
pace of the Qatari government again
users shouldn't be dictated to by by the
west and and whatever we believe to be
valuable and important in life you know
you you have to follow this no it's been
a slow process perhaps in some areas too
slow but progress has been made
virtually every day since we came here
and Abby's right it's a totally
different country the one we moved to
and it's a very enjoyable place to enjoy
let's get to why you came here right so
the last time many people would have
seen if they don't watch your your
commentaries now would have been when
you were riding unbelievably high at Sky
Premier League was on fire you guys were
the front men for it life was good you
were Superstars really a British TV
especially in football and then back do
you recognize any of that yeah just me
nice to watch you guys I love you guys
you're an integral part of my football
watching life and then Bang
do you regret saying the things you said
albeit they were so private because this
is
yes
um
I questioned whether
a young lady from Coventry my hometown
would know the offside law as she made
her debut
um the female lines were amazing yeah
um
I on air
because I was not sure who her father
was actually on air as we went to the
kickoff said and we also have a female
assistant we call them these days good
luck to her Sean I don't know I may have
gone to school with her dad she's from
my Manor so all the very best to her she
made a number of Errors first half
that I was insistent we didn't show
nor did we she got once absolutely spot
on uh the goal that scored against
Liverpool I believe when I spoke to her
the following day
she was great she said hey come on now
did you rang her to apologize yes of
course and she accepted the apology she
more than accepted she said I expected
this last week it's just a bit of fun
come on Casey that I'd never really come
across that word painter she said oh
come on it's just banter and and that I
suppose stuck in my mind and I said no
no I said Sean this is really serious
now it's got a life of its own I I have
to make this an official apology on
behalf of myself and Andy who's in
commentary now she went well right okay
I'm I'm waiting so I did and then she
went oh by the way
couple of things first half that you
didn't show thank goodness for that
thank you so we're not in that business
you know so yes in isolation those
those questioning whether she knew the
offside law was was
unacceptable without anybody honestly is
sports
television at the time very few people
would survive all their private
conversations being made public I don't
think that's that's not because
everyone's awful it's because the banter
that you alluded to earlier was very
prevalently I hate that word and I'd
never as I said I'd never used it but
Sean said to me I expected it last week
oh come on it was only about and I
suppose that was in my head and at the
time when you're on the defensive
because you can't get your head around
what's going on it's an extraordinary
place to be you know you've set the dogs
on many in in in in a different role
you've also been on the receipt so I've
been yeah
I I know what it's like it's a terrible
place if you had your time again yeah
would you have done anything different
in the way you responded Yes
what would you have done I would have
accepted quicker than what people were
saying to me was was uh accurate and I
would have understood sooner that what
what happened and shouldn't have done
um but you you
you're not in that place and
um but I've said many times to friends
given the same circumstances again of
course I would have
gone to things differently but you also
have to then factor in mental health
which I I I think people too quickly
dismiss less so now than they have for
the first time in my life I I found
myself in a very difficult place I just
I couldn't get my head around it peers
it it didn't at that time seem to be so
significant to to start the forest fire
that was engulfing us thank you
well coming up next a lot more from
Richard Keyes and Andy Gray and it gets
emotional
this is talk TV
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to my live special edition
of Piers Morgan Anderson from here in
Doha Qatar scene of the World Cup here's
more from my exclusive interview with
Richard keys and Andy Gray we've done
for any punches in the second part of
our very revealing and it turned out
emotional interview
Andy I mean you've alluded to the fact
that you had Suicidal Thoughts at one
stage yeah that would be serious yeah
that's serious I mean you talked about
it I I had a wonderful life
uh fortunate lucky uh I played 17 years
as a footballer it was glorious best
years of my life
I'll give you that yeah okay okay and uh
and then went to what uh in the sport I
love for a new broadcaster it was about
to revolutionize football in the way it
did and had 20 years there
so I suddenly found myself at a really
dark place
the house surrounded by people
and I knew I had
done something wrong of course I did
but I couldn't compute it
and my head was gone and it hadn't been
to my wife I don't know what would
happen I really don't care ritual is
amazing wonderful you really you were
that a lot yeah I was closely going down
the garden where I used to have a pool a
pond down at a garden with a little
bottle and a few pearls and I would I
would have let that
I was up at one day I was that bad yeah
but
I mean that's so horrific
people who normally will probably think
yeah you're kitten because you're too
somebody can see it in your face no even
as you read think about it again total
it's a very emotional thing
I couldn't work it out
I knew I'd done wrong but I thought you
know for two weeks I couldn't get out of
the house
um we were just surrounded by pressing
TV cameras and Crews and uh
there's weird
really weird but what's through it now
our arm through it now and your family
was what saved you yeah Rachel and the
kids
and Pals
you know friends people who
you learn who your friends are pierced
with things that happens to you and I I
think we both did them we both learned
did you know how how low Andy yes I was
there too
same oh feeling suicide oh peers really
you have no idea it's it's you know
it
he's right you can't explain you look
back now with a clear head and a clean
you go what come on what are you
thinking you know but when you're in
that place and and he's right you
couldn't the only I used to have to
leave my house from the from my back
Garden I would walk to a local uh
Nursery that was close by I got a taxi
and I flew out here actually because uh
NASA Al khalifi who I'd worked for
earlier 2008 and he wanted me to join
then and of course I should have done
when I was too comfortable I should have
taken this off if I didn't so he he
called and said look nobody's talking
about it out here why don't you come out
here but then the heat got too much and
I felt I had to back away for us because
it was going to bring too much attention
to this country and they didn't need to
inherit our problems at that time so so
we put it on a burner so in in effect I
lost two jobs and we lost two jobs in in
two weeks
um one of them of our own volition but
no it's a it's I think it was wrong that
you lost your job
well I talked about how it made you feel
well let me ask you can I ask you then
can I can I turn that on you yeah
because I I would like to know do you
think it was wrong we lost our jobs well
it's interesting you know when I've
looked at it all again it feels to me
like an overreaction by everybody
because I think that you you made
fulsome apologies I know Karen Brady for
example who is one of the bosses of West
Ham and when one of her players got
caught kicking a cat around horrendous
video came out she said everyone
deserves a second chance of forgiveness
and yet I remember her reaction to when
you two were sacked and it was a
different reaction and I felt there was
a real kind of uh Feeding Frenzy to do
you win which with hindsight now looks
like it was overdone but mainly because
you didn't say this on air and I do
think that everybody
anyone who was had all their private
conversations
put on to public domain I'm not sure
many people would survive it it went
some opiates I mean you've been in more
green rooms probably you could count had
conversation with guests off off make
and and if half half of the things that
you talk about will run the people would
be horrified private conversations
aren't what they why they're called a
private conversation Andy who let you
down most in the world of football that
you would have expected to defend you
when you look back
at that time yeah
lots of people I wouldn't are there any
of the stick in your mind I wouldn't
want you to name too many of them my
real friends were there without a shadow
of a day and I knew they I knew who they
were
um I mean Andy Townsend we've talked
about Andy he was one of my neighbors
then and I was sitting down in the
kitchen one day just head was all over
the place next minute the gate's all big
and this motorbike it's a rider comes
right down the drive he's got an extra
he's got an extra helmet and he's under
his arm he comes screeching in and it's
Andy takes it out it's like
what you come on I said what I'm getting
you out of here I said no now you know I
was I was he said yeah yeah come on put
this helmet on we'll get up to the gate
and then we'll do a runner I said no I
can't but that's the kind of friend that
was there but there was there were lots
of people that I looked after appears
various ways and various things that I
never heard from and I've never heard
from probably in 20 years let me ask you
man have you guys
I think every every bloke right we're
all how old are you now if you don't
realize I'm 50 next year no yeah 50 I
plus but how old are you guys
I'm I'm 65 business and and I am 67 in
two days and I'm 57. I think every I
think every bloke has probably gone
through a little bit of reevaluation in
recent years about what is appropriate
and not appropriate in terms of how you
act what what you say have you guys
since what happened to you have you gone
through that process yes and I sometimes
look at what you've got to say on
different matters and I think to myself
no peers come on because if if we are to
find a balance then we have to over
balance in One Direction in order to to
get back to the middle because for too
long men have had everything their own
way and and and we're looking to try and
find Middle Ground if we're not going to
do that just by us we in my view we've
got to go here and we have to accept a
lot of the things that irritate you
particularly and drag them to the center
ground and then we might find a better
battle exactly I know at the moment I
announce I've done this interview we all
know what's going to happen there'll be
people on Twitter why are you
interviewing those sexist dinosaurs
there's dinosaurs ruled the world for
about 300 million years
to those who think that's what you are
because of what happened 10 years ago
what do you say to them talk to anyone
who knows me
really I can't defend myself it's easy
to defend myself you know but that would
be wrong people know me it appears
people who have been my friends and
talked to my family anyone who knows me
ask them and if they turn around and say
to you yeah he's definitely a sexist
then I would be very very surprised so I
I
I said if you were offered jobs again in
the UK would you go back
um my primary I am deeply loyal to the
company that I work for and with
um I think there is a process at which
now I would be able to yeah engage yes
um but I I there is no suggestion of
that being the case
um but yeah I listen I
I find it extraordinary honestly because
in life things happen for a reason I
believe I wouldn't wish upon any but
well I might one or two exceptions but I
wouldn't wish on the majority
um what we went through but I as a
result have lived a a wonderful life I
mean I feel and I might be completely
wrong here but just from the interview
you gave to the Telegraph and from just
things I've picked up
and even today actually that I think the
maybe you've come to terms with what
happened
better in the sense that you're ready to
sort of leave it I feel with you Richard
I'm currently if I'm wrong there's still
a lot of anger about what happened no I
I just don't and resent them no I don't
think that's necessarily true I'm I'm
very comfortable at the place we're in
um but I I I will I will always carry a
little bit of anger in my back pocket I
don't think that's a bad thing if if
that is to be used
um by way of motivation then then I I'm
very happy with that as well but no
there are a number of it's it's it's
Instinct peers it's it's it's something
that you would do you would want to know
what happened I cut that's how my mind
is if you let bitterness eat you up
there's no better than that in this way
how would you categorize it it still is
a back a back pocket yeah full of anger
yeah that's all when you think about it
yeah and and I do for him when I see my
mates out there as distressed as he was
talking about it I feel protective and
then and then that stirs you know a
little bit more of me to get on the
front foot and that's that's how it's
been stumbling quick football questions
I can't not ask you give them away at
the World Cup in your backyard but can
England win the World Cup
they can they can will they
that's a different question they're
capable yeah what will it depend on well
all sorts of things
are getting not losing care and would be
obviously a huge it doesn't look fit to
me now his ankle looks dodgy if it's not
England who do you fancy who do you
think one of my one of my favorites a
really strong I thought Belgium would
make a real impression here I also think
Portugal with my old buddy Christiana
you think he was right to do the
interview with me no why not at this
time of his career I thought it was
badly timed I didn't think he needed to
volunteer for the aggravation that it's
brought him
um where are you I would have said to
him listen I'm very very keen that you
sit down and talk with me but let's get
you sorted out first because we don't
want to taint the Legacy we don't want
you leaving Manchester United under a
cloud and there's no reason Roy Keane
left after a similar Outburst on Manu TV
and he's revealed
I don't think a few months problems with
Eric 10 hard and the coach he had never
heard of before that rendering I don't
think it's gonna make any difference to
the Legacy do you think he'd say
Manchester United fans well yeah let's
forget he remains one of the greatest
players I've ever had and in terms of
what if they what if they have a view of
Ronaldo the same as you've just
suggested public do still of us it's
gonna be a long time you know what
Cristiano said to me you're never going
to please everybody so you might as well
be true to yourself that's true anyway
guys but you see what we've done we're
now interviewing you
know what it's great it's great to see
you
enjoying your own in your own uh
enjoyment I've enjoyed my time here and
I'm glad you guys have enjoyed it and I
hope this interview goes away to you
know well how do people realize what
you've been through and well then we
start appears it is kind of you to offer
the invitation for us to come and talk
to you and I know one of your objectives
when you took this job was to uncancel
people and if you've played a role we oh
I think so don't you I don't think you
should be ignore I don't think almost
anyone should be irrevocably cancerous I
agree I'm not sure what more you can do
than show remorse so you wish you hadn't
said those things but they were said
privately a lot of other people were
saying similar stuff at the time I heard
them right in some cases right in the
football world and I think that the
reaction was overdone you're very kind
to have given us this opportunity good
to see you thank you come on you're
going for a swim
good to see you
well coming up after the devastating
Revelation that Team USA had not lost to
England last week was that result of
start wake up call or a freak result
from the U.S Defender Alexi Lalas is
uncensored next he's gonna cop it
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the special edition of
Piers Morgan on censored live here in
Doha Qatar scene of the World Cup well I
watched England via the us at the
weekend or Friday wasn't it with my head
in my hands it was a dismal display by
England a nil nil board draw of course
the US by not losing basically went as
far as almost having a ticket reception
through every major city in the country
it was for them one of the Great Moments
of their lives for us a terrible night
at the office what I'm joined Now by
former US football legend Fox Sports
lead football honest I actually love as
well Alexi welcome thank you it's
appears
to be told to be unsensitive pleasure
not probably the least sensitive person
I know in World Sports that's how I roll
that's how I roll so look I was gutted
on Friday by the Mr jury of our
performance only because I saw it it was
wonderful well I know you enjoyed it uh
jumping on my grade but only because
we've been so good and thrilling against
Iran you now have to play Iran yeah and
you got to beat them yep to actually go
through what do you think is going to
happen I think a rhino bunker uh I think
that the US will have plenty of
possession uh and I think ultimately it
will come down to you know a set piece
type of situation but I think the U.S
will find a way through I think the U.S
is better than Iran the interesting
thing is you know the the narratives
obviously that are around and you know
soccer called soccer football well
soccer mirrors mirrors life and the
politics and culture and all that kind
of stuff so obviously all of our
incredible history and our contentious
history with that country in 1998 in the
World Cup we actually played Iran and I
was part of that team and we tried to
put that away you know and I think it
was a real mistake because we came up
against a team that kind of harnessed
and really used that you know that
narrative and all that kind of thing
yeah and they and it fueled them and so
I hope Greg berhalter the coach of the
U.S team comes out in this game tomorrow
and has the has the players understand
the importance although this time
interestingly you've got the Iranian
players themselves making a stand yep
about the oppression of women in their
own country which is incredibly heroic
of them and brave and brave but in a way
they're having their own little
political battle with their own country
they are and so it remains to be seen
where the U.S fits into into it here but
ultimately this is to go to get out of
the group and that's a that was a be a
big you know it's not we haven't done it
before but it's a big step for the US
here to figure out a way to get this win
against Iran you know that we you know
break things have been fantastic people
are watching right so record my
appearance people are watching yes
exactly I think it's probably because of
my contributions but they are record
ratings what does that tell you about
where football is going our football now
in America well we are a soccer culture
whether you want to acknowledge it or
recognize it or not we are different we
don't need to apologize for what we are
or what we aren't we are a soccer
community and culture that is Discerning
that is passionate that has a history
and as I said you know in the past we've
had this inferiority complex and a lot
of it is relative to to the English
let's be let's be honest very
understandable well it's understandable
we need to shed that and I think that we
have made this smarter better looking
you know we're coming for you I mean
we're coming for you in terms of players
uh we're coming for you in terms of
coaches and by the way we're coming for
you in terms of ownership So eventually
we will own that issue you own my team
awesome you're welcome you're welcome
for the uh the money that he is spending
for your team you're sitting pretty
right now Rams well you guys are okay
right now you actually what's up yeah
there you go we're going well well done
you were one of America's greatest ever
football players of football it's
debatable but whatever okay do you miss
it do you miss playing at the high level
come to a World Cup yeah I mean I love
what I do Pierce I I mean you can tell
that you love what you do I love what
they can they can pry this job from my
cold dead redheaded American hands okay
I love it so and they're coming all the
youngins are coming now and they they
it's easy from the couch or whatever to
do it but as you as you know it takes
some level of school the skill and I get
young players that come to me all the
time and say listen if you can find
something that you know is a jumping off
type of thing go for a it's very hard to
replicate will soccer as you call it in
America will it ever get up with the
other major national sports do you think
I think it will but we will always have
would it take us to win a World Cup no
that I mean that's not a fantasy that
doesn't change every I mean it's huge it
would be wonderful and it would
certainly bring a lot of people into the
tent but this tent is getting bigger and
as I said before it's a really unique
soccer tent and we're you know you guys
are insufferable over there with what
with what you are we put up with you uh
and there's an incredible relationship
in history with your with your country
uh and your people in the and your
soccer culture we have a special
relationship you do you do you do and
you couldn't possibly lose to Wales
tomorrow because you're so you're so
good and you're you're good it's
definitely coming home at some point uh
without a doubt so I congratulate you
ahead just to remind you it has come
home just not since 1966 right but it
has to come home again right you know
like you know the invented the sport and
everybody else perfected it I understand
that I understand all of that Alexa I
want to talk to you again maybe uh
Wednesday that's it that's it I'm here
good luck to you and your country
tomorrow I'm just happy that you guys
are here I want England and the US to
both go through absolutely agree on that
absolutely my friend I just saying that
Alex what a legend that's it for me I'll
be back tomorrow at 9pm whatever you're
up to keep it uncensored
[Music]
thank you
[Music]